that's like requiem for a dream I can
only watch all I remember is Bryant
marlon wayans is ass his naked ass on
the bed that's the only thing I remember
of it oh yeah I have to say in that
movie and I've told them this before
good ass like in terms of I'm being real
I mean this is a roundabout way to get
to marlon wayans ass just open up with
hereditary I knew she was gonna bring up
yeah Marlon Wayans ass
what a great ass good writing man yeah I
don't member you see getting is he also
doing something that doesn't want to do
because of drugs no I don't remember him
being I think the hour yeah yeah yeah
she's great in that yeah when she's like
it's like like it's almost like a like a
security camera and she's like in the
inner kitchen like moving over that one
show and the show starts talking her
yeah baby on the ceiling call yeah if
you're incited hey guys if you haven't
seen it that's it's a must watch one at
least one time
it's Arnoff ski ride that he did Black
Swan all right like you did the wrestler
do you the rest the wrestler would make
him work I think you did that as well
you didn't like mother
oh you're like mother Ida like mother
why cuz I like that it was like this
poem the whole thing was this like weird
palma by yes allegory about women and
like how people like you use them up and
crying it's really good it really I get
I totally got well it's more like art in
Miami
I like that I mean I also thought that
shots were just crazy like going from
the war to the thing and then then it
goes too much like with clave yeah I saw
one if you haven't seen it
Nicolas Cage's Mandy Oh Mandy Oh Mandy's
great dude did you see Mandy flat face
ayat oh my god a 5/8 left that Mandy
dude have you seen Mandy what [ __ ] yeah
he's 100 yeah I showed you finally I
told you watch in the theatres he was
out in theatres for a minute you started
the movie there no I want to oh yeah
dude there's let me see something about
Mandy dude number 1 from the beginning
of the movie you're like ok this is an
complete LSD trip just in terms of
choice the color it was yeah somebody's
also somebody that kind of knew what he
wanted to make you could tell that up
front so don't you watch a movie you go
oh they don't really know what they they
don't want to do well it shifts you know
yeah but this guy right from beginning
you're like okay I'm in good hands
because this guy this is he knows what
he wants to do yeah he wants to make a
statement right and it's a revenge movie
which I love which I love revenge movie
you gotta hate box
I haven't don't we have a hate box I
know you tell me to have a hate box
I told you that yeah wait what did I say
this was outside of like The Improv all
remember this is like this is when we
really started to become friends I think
[Music]